♪♪♪
>>> THE UNTHINKABLE HAS FINALLY
HAPPENED.
OUR NATION TORN.
BROKEN.
YOU COULD MOVE TO CANADA.
BUT YOU LOVE YOUR COUNTRY.
WHAT CAN A PERSON LIKE YOU DO?
>> WHAT IF THERE WAS A PLACE
WHERE THE UNTHINKABLE DIDN'T
HAPPEN?
WHERE LIFE COULD CONTINUE FOR
PROGRESSIVE AMERICANS JUST AS
BEFORE?
♪♪♪
>> NOW THERE IS.
WELCOME TO THE BUBBLE.
COMING IN JANUARY 2017, THE
BUBBLE IS A PLANNED COMMUNITY OF
LIKE-MINDED FREE THINKERS.
AND NO ONE ELSE.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> SO, IF YOU'RE AN OPEN MINDED
PERSON, COME HERE, AND CLOSE
YOURSELF IN.
IN HERE, IT'S LIKE THE ELECTION
NEVER HAPPENED.
>> WHILE WHO-KNOWS-WHAT-THE-HELL
IS HAPPENING OUTSIDE IN THEIR
AMERICA, THE BUBBLE WILL BE A
FULLY FUNCTIONING CITY-STATE.
>> WITH THINGS EVERYBODY LOVES:
LIKE HYBRID CARS, USED
BOOKSTORES, AND SMALL FARMS
WITH THE RAWEST MILK YOU'VE EVER
TASTED.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
[ CASH REGISTER RINGS ]
>> NOW THAT'S MORE LIKE IT.
EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE IN THE
BUBBLE, YOU'LL STILL STAY FULLY
CONNECTED TO THE WORLD OUTSIDE.
>> WE'VE STREAMLINED OUR HIGH
SPEED INTERNET WITH ONLY THE
GOOD SITES.
LIKE HUFF-PO, DAILY KOS, NETFLIX
DOCUMENTARIES ABOUT SUSHI RICE,
THE EXPLOSIVE COMEDY OF
MCSWEENEY'S.
>> HMM, CLEVER.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> NEED ENTERTAINMENT?
THE BUBBLE HAS SO MUCH TO DO!
>> GO TO THE BAR AND ENGAGE WITH
A WIDE ARRAY OF DIVERSE
VIEWPOINTS.
>> YES, EXACTLY!
>> TOTALLY!
>> RIGHT?
>> THE BUBBLE IS A DIVERSE
COMMUNITY AND SAFE SPACE FOR
EVERYONE.
>> WE DON'T SEE COLOR HERE.
BUT WE CELEBRATE IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND UNLIKE THE REST OF
AMERICA, ANYBODY IS WELCOME TO
JOIN US.
ONE-BEDROOM APARTMENTS START AT
$1.9 MILLION.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
>> PLANNING IS UNDER WAY TO GIVE
YOU EVERYTHING YOU NEED.
>> EXCEPT POLICE OR FIREMEN.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T FOUND ANY WHO
WOULD AGREE TO LIVE HERE.
>> IT'S THEIR AMERICA NOW.
>> WE'LL BE FINE, RIGHT HERE IN
THE BUBBLE.
♪♪♪
JOIN US!
STARTING IN 2017!
>> THE BUBBLE.
IT'S BROOKLYN.
WITH A BUBBLE ON IT!
[ LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE ]